[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au bout du roi vivement
la plus belle vue meilleur
ils ne savent pas se compenser en bas
ils le savent pas qui si c'est nous les
rois les rois du monde font tout ce
qu'ils veulent ils ont du monde autour
de mes ils sont seuls dans leur château
là haut ils sont vides
[Musique]
et se protège de tout mettre de l'amour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à quoi ça sert d'être sur la terre si
c'est pour faire nos vies un peu de
foncer le temps c'est comme le temps
pour vivre il a que ça Dark Horse
[Musique]
après jour nuit après lui à quoi ça sert
d'être sur la terre si c'est pour faire
nos villages toutes ces seins c'est
comme le pardon tu vois comme ça on se
parle mal de la mort on sait bien qu'on
fait pas nous on fait l'amour
[Musique]
on sait que le temps le penser comme le
gars d'importance ou pas mal de la mort
on sait bien qu'on fait Batman nous on
fait l'amour on fait la vie jour après
jour nuit après nuit quoi ça sert d'être
sur la
[Applaudissements]